avec ses 6700 mètres carrés ces 500
postes de travail et ses 170 places de
parking proxima 5 est la dernière
réalisation en date pour cfc
développement un promoteur immobilier
actif depuis la fin des années 70 sur
l'agglomération soit en net 1 300 mille
mètres carrés construite sur 51 10
peut-être plus d'ailleurs j'ai jamais
fait des comptes on a détruit un
immeuble qui était qui avait été
construit il y à 35 ans environ qui
faisait environ 4500 m² et qui faisait
rez-de-chaussée plus de niveaux sur la
partie conservée en sous-sol sur les
fondations existantes vont construire un
immeuble plus haut en r + 5 plus lourd
20 % plus lourd voilà le déjà là le
paramètres techniques spécifiques liés à
cet ensemble
la direction régionale d'aînés disent ça
viendra prendre possession des locaux
dans les prochains mois eun et 10
arrivée en 2011 à saint quentin en
yvelines et qui s'était alors installé à
montigny le bretonneux ce qui nous
attire à 50 ans et le développement
économique la présence de nombreuses
entreprises la présence des transports
saint quentin est une terre d'innovation
dans lequel nous on peut nouer de
multiples partenariats avec ben les
autres entreprises du territoire des
start-up l'agglomération saint quentin
en yvelines dispose de 5 millions de m²
d'immobilier d'entreprise avec encore
deux cent cinquante mille mètres carrés
en développement rajustement des
opérations comme celle du proxima 5 sur
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui nous
pouvons garder les entreprises sur le
territoire qui sont installés dans deux
les mieux deux ans de l'immobilier
obsolète et qui grâce à ces nouvelles
opérations justement peuvent déménager
mais en même temps se regrouper on est
sur une dynamique que ce soit sur le
padula que ce soit sur le centre de
saint quentin donc guyancourt montini on
a vraiment une belle dynamique de
projets immobiliers